it was also he was the first dog who got
me thinking so what if I didn't want to
keep also he wasn't gonna find a woman
anybody else and he'd be put down so a
hundred dogs became 200 dogs and then
300 dogs and and then all of a sudden we
thought okay so how can you stop helping
them do so many out there to me and I
hope to them it's their little mountain
where nobody's gonna hurt them again and
where they're lucky they might find home
I said what the or a mutt
is the product of a survivor with a
survivor not that I think three dogs or
not I mean any dog any animal is
beautiful but if a mutt gets to survive
past his first months of life on the
street he's pretty much bulletproof and
Costa Rica has a serious problem with
strays we have about two million dogs on
the streets but the streets are not home
to anyone
first I went to visit promoters my me
gustan los los alamitos pero realmente
el alma de esto le
see no cure low psyche Telesto a las
casas tamara's y vamos a tener siento
Chen Tetris parathas entonces en ese
momento super problematic Odessa demos
pero nunca sermo pensando vamos it has
to start with children children have to
grow up knowing the good and the bad I
mean how to treat an animal properly
that's a nice part how to consider part
of your family and not an object and
also what happens that you don't but
people still need a little bit of
coaching there and it can't happen but
it has to happen from school it has to
be taught to kids and kids will teach
their parents
[Music]
tanea on supple
echoes it in your bathrobe is data
yester convinced either case what will a
marvelous animals turning estaría well
creo que el mejor Rousseau play Polaris
in honor I kissed Elena and where is
Nick OH
I'll get her I'll get her back yeah what
else
since we don't euthanize the dog for any
reason at all some of her dogs needed
therapy we had dogs that would come to
us dragging their back legs because they
had been hit by a car
months ago and a few sessions of therapy
and in a month they were wobbling and
walking and then strong enough to get
their muscles back and it's wonderful
dogs in general are so resilient so much
braver than we are and they they take
hell with such class little dogs I've
seen though or the dogs that get the
news part of their ability to function
have to make up with personality and
they do and so you see little wiener
dogs sort of dawn on say they have weak
backs and it happens a lot and you see
them and they're happy and they feel no
self-pity
they just feel it's another challenge
and dogs function on challenges you see
them I mean don't go past this point and
they'll try to go past this point don't
eat that and they'll try to eat but
don't survive and they will survive
[Music]
I noticed America minnie-rella personas
complicado part element alpha rapidly
are recommended i stock antivirus is
ki-moon cup with impressive as a bit for
Paris economy so now we just have the
longest troughs we place the
strategically place to Sachs the guy
standing it's like it's like it's a
ceremony and they all come and they
start getting in and shouldering their
way in and and some of them will lie on
top of the food so we do have to patrol
behind them but basically that's their
that's a routine it comes full circle
because we feed them and then we have
these really sturdy sacks leftover so
what we do is we collect the poop during
the day and we we fill the sacks and
then the sacks are placed in special
bins that are later connected by they're
connected by a company that specializes
in sort of composting that's our thing
so it's not my face or the tossing in
the river
[Music]
at least some of my proudest moments are
when I can see dogs walking and running
around here that were either dogs that
were supposed to be put down for
whatever reason or really weren't
supposed to survive we have and that
that for that we have to thank our vets
territorial representa muchas cosas
representa todo lo que una persona puede
hacer para cambiar el mundo pero al
mismo tiempo y muy triste mente
representa lo mal que estamos en costa
rica con respecto a lotta Mencia
responsable de mess castas es un lugar
donde yaga todos los casos que las otras
personas completamente volte erin su
cara
when you get into this into rescuing
animals you come into contact with the
lowest lowest form of humanity very
often but even if it's very few sparks
compared to very big blotches of
darkness it there enough there enough to
make it worth it
entonces es una combination de
sentimientos sentimientos muy buenos
cuando la Gramma's excelente resultados
he sentimental muy triste z-- cuando
ellos lo que una mano whereas earlier
una mascota
oh c'mon okay sir Leon ser que no se
puede fin there a lot of the dogs we
have here are all messed up
they've had a hard life and they get wet
and dirty and muggy in but they're happy
they've healed the inside and that's
sometimes that's the hardest part you
think of human beings I mean how much
makeup you put on if you're sad if
you're got a broken heart it's not gonna
it's not gonna go away we make
every dog becomes your baby and at the
beginning it was harder but then after
years of watching these dogs who have
had so much fun here just gravitate
towards people when there's a public
walk you understand that they all want a
home so when somebody takes them that
the bittersweet part of letting go the
bitter part is gone it's like I'm
trusting this person with what I think
this dog wants and I think they all want
homes it's not how many times you're
happy it's how deeply happy you can be
and I don't think I could be happy
turning my back sometimes like I get
asked why do you keep doing it you know
because somebody has to take over
somebody has to learn that it is
possible to give this to dogs to have
dogs that don't have homes and I have
engaged in and sentenced to a death if
they're not adopted if I could do this
imagine a government with funding they
deserve at least this at least as much
and if if we can't stop them from being
born with God then guarantee them some
happiness and in a future that doesn't
involve cages so I can't stop I can't
[Music]
you
[Music]